dimanche en fin d'après midi sylvain 11
ans un petit garçon de bohain près de
saint-quentin dans l'aisne disparaît
sans laisser de traces celle alerte
générale dans la petite ville on ne
retrouvera l'enfant que 16 heures plus
tard inde m
au fond d'un puits de ce 15 mai ne vous
trompez pas ce qui était tout à fait
normal l'ancien alerté la gendarmerie il
était 9 heures et 9 heures et midi soir
je jeu sont amenés aussi tous les autres
ça s'arrange et des autres forts de leur
carnet de santé et d enlever son idée
qui passent facilement
peut-être alors vas-y honda signalée y
retrouver les vivants et dans depuis
sylvain petit me raconter comment ça
s'est passé
c'est du simple jouet d'habitude
d'habitude je joue pas le jardin végétal
et fusionner et je me suis engagé comme
son gré à la terre je sais c'est là et
que je savais qu'il est un robinet aux
puits or il est de retourner à la maison
je me suis lavé les mains et je posé un
pied sur les dunks déjà bien fort du
alors je mens puis je t'assure et j'ai
bluffé bas et la dalle mkc jesper kce
s'est emporté je tends porte
puis alors quand tu arrivé en bas du
dessous si vous n'êtes plus rien j'ai
appelé j'ai appelé je vous jure que
quand je courais plus arrivé à 8h jeudi
vont reyel revêt chercher un jour
changer j'ai subi la dacie dieu je sors
dans dit mais tu as pas eu peur avant
nous sommes à côté du puits où sylvain
est tombé il y a trois jours est à côté
de moi monsieur vous avez trouvé
c'est vous qui avez trouvé sylvain
comment avez vous vu qu'il était là
quand j'arrivais en quelques mètres
d'ici j'ai mis le tuyau de remontées
d'eau qui bougeait quoi je suis avancé
j'ai vu qu'il manquait une plaque on me
suis dit l'état il était dans le fond il
était dangereux et après il est passé au
dessus des plaques et des tôles
j'ai vu j'ai déjà regardé d'enfants je
l' ai vu qui se levait du fond du court
c'est saïd a crié ils étaient contents
donc grillé ou secours de foix et puis
j'ai dit une bouche paul vais chercher
mon corps pour les pompiers sont arrivés
j'étais content de sortir